[Music]
and albatross delivered your invitation
you've acquired your wand ridden the
enchanted zeppelin
made some fast friends and are finally
ready for the adventure you've dreamed
of
your entire life your first day at
magnificent marigold's
magical macadamy but before you can
learn your first spell
you must get through the most
nerve-wracking moment of the year
the sorting ceremony when you put on the
sorting hat
you hear a voice ah you're an
interesting one
every year i choose one student for a
special
challenge and i choose you
the magicalm academy had eight founders
and they established our four houses two
by two
by two by two i alone know
which witches founded which but there
was once a mysterious
fifth house lost to time but full of
secrets and powerful artifacts
if you can tell me who founded each
house
i'll sort you into whichever you want
however if you can also tell me the name
of the secret fifth house i'll let you
sort
into it and you'll inherit everything
you discover
the two founders of each house wore
different
colored hats with non-matching symbols
no founder started more than one house
of fun flame and imagines one was a
founder
of giant eye and the other of longmas
and of miraculo and rimbellby one
established longmas and the other
mermaid
finally septimus didn't found
vidopnir so who
founded what and what's the name of the
secret house
the hardest part of solving this logic
puzzle is knowing where to start
no rule by itself is enough to assign a
founder to his or her house
so the next best thing would be to
combine a pair of rules to learn
something
four and five are good candidates to try
that with
because they contain a lot of
constraints
and both mention longmass miraculo
and rimblebee's hats both have moons
which means that no matter who ends up
in longness
moons will be accounted for that means
imagineez
who also has moons can't have founded
longmas so she's in giant eye and
fun flame founded longness miraculous
hat
is red so he can't be there so he must
be
in mermaid and ramble be in longmas
halfway there now we can place septimus
rule six keeps him out of vadopnir and
his yellow hat
out of giant eye so he must be in
merrimaid
of the founders left deepmeyer and
hypnotum
both have stars so each must go into a
different house
taking up the remaining space in giant
eye and leaving
one spot open in vidopner which tremenda
must fill
tremendous blue hat keeps deepmeyer out
of the doppner
so we can easily place her and finally
hypnotum
now that those founders are sorted we
can start to search for the secret house
if you don't have it yet here are a few
hints
one good strategy for a puzzle like this
is to look for patterns or unusual
pieces of information
first of all there's the school's
obsession with the letter m
right down to its motto which translates
from latin to
m is a magic letter curiously
every founder has exactly one m in their
name
and each m is in a different position
that means that the m's can put them in
order
one through eight we know we need to
solve the logic puzzle before finding
the secret house
so there must be something critical
about the connection between the
founders
and their houses here's where a pattern
emerges
every founder and house have exactly the
same number of letters
this allows the founders to line up with
their houses
quite nicely the first letters don't
spell
anything but let's look at the m's in
the names again
and the letters they line up with
m i n o t a
u r you shout out minotaur to a stunned
dining hall and a secret passage grinds
open the wonders of house minotaur
are yours if you want them but being the
first
and only resident of the secret house
would come at a high price
loneliness so which will it be
riches or friendship whichever you
choose
you're probably looking for more
problems to pit your mind against
brilliant has you covered brilliance
many courses
in math science and computer science
feature
interactive challenges and conundrums
that will help you
take your mastery to the next level you
can try it out today at brilliant.org
ted-ed and the first 833 of you to use
that link
will receive 20 off the annual premium
subscription fee
[Music]